I wasn't so much interested when I was
in high school of computers although I
was more interesting in reading fiction
actually but later on I discovered that
it's it's a bit easier to make a career
out of being a software engineer
especially in the in this part of the
world where I was born my path is the
emerging market leader in an exploding
new category that we think our readers
should know about called robotic process
automation or RPA now what that means is
a big businesses around the world there
are hundreds if not hundreds of
thousands of hours of workers jobs every
day that basically are repetitive menial
jobs on your computer like filling out
expense forms or moving contacts from
one spreadsheet to another basically
just taking all this menial work and
allowing software do it I moved to us
and so I started working for Microsoft
it was in early 2000 I worked there for
five years
and then I I returned to Romania to
start a company which in retrospect it's
the is the craziest idea that I ever had
in my life it was the opposite of
immediate success it was a big struggle
were like almost ten years until we
raise our first money
it was everyday struggle to pay salaries
you know having the death sentence you
know above your head it's it's quite
terrible many people ask me today there
is a lot of pressure and I said no it's
a different type of pressure I prefer
this type of pressure than the one you
know from 10 years ago
[Music]
uipath we think is the market leader
because it is working with so many of
the leading companies in finance and
manufacturing and oil and gas the
implementation and the maintenance of
these robots the services is four to
five x as lucrative as the software
subscription itself so for every dollar
a customer spends on uipath they could
be spending four dollars with one of
these players like cognizant which means
that they become uipath salesforce
daniel Dinah's who still owns between 20
and 25 percent of the company is worth
more than a billion dollars which makes
us call him the first bot billionaire
2016 was an unexpectedly good year for
our PA so we've seen really the good
side so now or even increased a lot and
I was fortunate to be introduced to a
great firm like XO we grew 70 times from
death and it's in a span of just two
years I would say that we live on the
edge the life right now it's it's really
you have what you have a rocket and you
drive it and it's very high-speed you
just have to avoid start
you
[Music]